[Música]
estaba un científico en la en el control
de migración de un aeropuerto en eeuu
este es simpatiquísimo lugar donde te
hacen simpatiquísimas preguntas como a
qué bien eeuu con tiempo se va a quedar
trae mucho dinero eso este terrorista y
cosas por el estilo
el científico contesta que tiene un
congreso se va a quedar una semana no
trae mucho dinero porque científico
y al final después de aclarar que no era
un terrorista llega la última pregunta y
usted aquí se dedica a yo hago
matemáticas responde y ya ven cómo son
los de migración medio
pocos hitos contesta con un burlón
acaray
pero quiero las matemáticas ya están
hechas
el matemático simplemente es una sonrisa
acento condescendientemente así como
este el siguió su camino para pronto le
dio el avión e irónicamente adentro de
un aeropuerto pero más allá de el tonito
de la pregunta la cuestión es
perfectamente legítima las matemáticas
no están hechas ya porque vivo cualquier
ciencia que elijamos la astronomía por
decir algo ellos investigan para
desentrañar la realidad desarrollando la
tecnología exploran los confines del
universo para descubrir de descubrir
teorías pero en todos los años que
tenemos contacto con las matemáticas
vemos que las ecuaciones se resuelven
los números se operan las fórmulas se
utilizan en general vemos que las
matemáticas se usan no se hacen
entonces por qué se ríe el protagonista
de nuestra historia cómo es que se hacen
las matemáticas
pues para mí hacer matemáticas se basa
en dos pilares fundamentales
aparentemente contradictorios pero con
una historia que los une
la primera parte de hacer matemáticas es
muy parecida a ser un detective y como
todo detective lo primero que
necesitamos es un caso resolver pero
llegados a esta parte quiero hacer una
advertencia y es que esta charla sobre
matemáticas
contiene matemáticas así como cuando
compran un bote de crema de maní dice
este producto puede contener manías así
pero si alguien de repente tiene ganas
de llorar pues alza la mano nos
detenemos y el organizador va y los
abraza ok listo entonces seguimos
necesitamos un caso a resolver entonces
uno fácil como sabemos que los ángulos
de un triángulo suman 180 grados
a todos en algún momento en la escuela
no lo soy no lo hicieron pero
de verdad nos consta como sabemos que es
cierto pues bueno para demostrarlo los
matemáticos al igual que los detectives
nos basamos en los hechos esa
información que ya sabemos que es
verdadera y también nos apoyamos de una
que otra mañana detectivesca en este
caso la mañana simplemente es extender
este lado del triángulo de allí
hacer lo mismo con el otro extender esa
recta y por último pasar una paralela
por ese punto ok ahora sí ocupando el
hecho de que este ángulo es igual a éste
porque son ángulos correspondientes a
dos paralelas por la misma razón ese
ángulo es igual ese y como los ángulos
opuestos por el vértice son iguales ese
ángulo es iguales
y pues como pueden ver la suma de los
tres hace 180 grados y como en ningún
momento ocupamos la característica de un
triángulo en especial un triángulo en
particular pues esto se cumple para
cualquier tipo de triángulo que nosotros
propongamos ahí estaría demostrado que
la suma de los ángulos de 180 grados
pero alguien tenía me podría decir oye
pero es que no a mí a mí no me consta
eso de que los ángulos correspondientes
y los ángulos opuestos por el vértice
eso no me consta como sé que es cierto
y bueno están en todo su derecho pero
teníamos ahí tendríamos un problema y es
que si nos ponemos a jugar de los hechos
difícilmente no vamos a dudar de la
conclusión entonces sería bueno que todo
lo que demostramos
se construyera a partir de una de unos
hechos tan pero tan evidentes que nadie
pudiera dudar de ellos una especie de
verdades absolutas
verdades absolutas eso de verdad existe
pues eso creía un matemático llamado
kleenex de 300 años antes de cristo que
postuló cinco axiomas cinco verdades tan
pero tan evidentes que nadie podría
dudar de su veracidad
veamos si ustedes están de acuerdo
número 12 pasa siempre una línea recta
ok la segunda un segmento de recta se
puede extender tanto como se quiera
ok parece que es factible se vale acción
mal número 2 dado un punto y un radio se
puede trazar una única circunferencia
con centro en ese punto y con ese radio
axioma número 4 todos los ángulos de 90
grados son iguales entre sí
y pues como veo que nadie está llorando
pues vayamos a la última verdad evidente
que dice
dado dos rectas no paralelas y una
transversal a ellas y la suma de los
ángulos correspondientes internos es
menor a 180 grados entonces las rectas
inter sacarán de dicho lado
pues así que digas hoy que evidente la
verdad es que no
por suerte alguien se tomó una molestia
en encontrar un enunciado que significa
lo mismo pero mucho más fácil de
entender que dice dada una recta y un
punto fuera de ella pasa una única
paralela
pues con estas cinco verdades evidentes
de euclides en efecto se pudo demostrar
absolutamente toda la geometría por más
de dos mil años la llamada geometría
euclidiana sentando las bases y el
método con el que hacemos matemáticas
hasta el día de hoy el método de deducir
rigurosamente como un detective a partir
de las verdades fundamentales que
tenemos para estar seguros así de que
estamos llegando a nuevas verdades ese
es el primer pilar los matemáticos
hacemos verdades gracias a nuestra
rigurosidad
quizá para sería sorpresa que las
matemáticas puedan ser rigurosas
pregunte en la cualquiera que haya
sufrido con el val d'or de álgebra en la
prepa
pero el otro pilar es bastante menos
intuitivo y justamente tiene que ver con
el fin de la geometría euclidiana y es
que durante todos esos años que reinó
esta geometría
pues al igual que muchos de nosotros al
escuchar la quinta verdad varios
matemáticos pusieron cara como de
axioma y es que la quinta verdad no
parece para nada evidente por lo menos
no en comparación a las otras cuatro por
lo que muchos matemáticos se preguntaron
oye y no será de la quinta no es una
verdad absoluta sino que se puede
demostrar con las otras cuatro
dicho esto los matemáticos empezaron a
intentar demostrar la quinta verdad a
partir de las otras cuatro para no
hacerles el cuento largo spoiler jamás
pudieron pero en sus intentos por
demostrarlo ocuparon un razonamiento que
cambió la historia de las matemáticas
para siempre
los que pensaron fue
pues si de veras de veras
la quinta verdad es cierta y la podemos
demostrar a partir de las otras cuatro
pues si nosotros suponemos que la quinta
verdad no se cumple nos vamos a llegar a
una contradicción les voy a poner un
ejemplo alguna vez
[Música]
katzav o la mentira de alguien haciendo
que suelte la sopa hasta que se
contraiga él solito
pues así los matemáticos supusieron que
la quinta verdad no se cumplía y esperan
llegar a una contradicción como dije la
cosa es que jamás lo lograron
esto porque otro matemático demostró que
las cuatro primero las cuatro primeras
verdades eran perfectamente consistentes
con la negación de la quinta es decir
que existía una geometría en la que no
era cierto en la quinta verdad una nueva
geometría donde no es cierto que dada
una recta y un punto fuera de ella pase
en una única paralela dicho de otra
manera una nueva geometría donde pasan
muchas paralelas dando origen a una
nueva geometría en donde se puede
demostrar cosas por ejemplo como que los
ángulos de un triángulo ahora van a
sumar siempre menos de 180 grados
y como este resultado los matemáticos
como buenos detectives que son
encontraron muchas otras cosas como que
en esta geometría no pueden existir los
cuadrados o que podemos tener triángulos
con ángulos de cero grados pero con área
positiva y así muchas cosas
y si ponemos atención esta no es la
única manera de negar la quinta verdad
así como supusimos que puede pasar una
única paralela o que pueden pasar muchas
paralelas también podemos suponer que no
pasa
ninguna paralela dando origen a otra
nueva geometría distinta igual de válida
que las anteriores donde esta vez se
puede demostrar que los ángulos de un
triángulo suman siempre más de 180
grados
estas geometrías se llaman en geometría
hiperbólica y geometría elíptica
respectivamente y ampliaron el horizonte
de lo que se quería posible hacer en
matemáticas
a lo mejor alguno de ustedes están
pensando presa es una tontería una
ociosidad esas geometrías no me sirven
de nada si claramente la geometría que
rige en nuestro mundo es la geometría de
toda la vida de la geometría euclidiana
no
pues nunca más irónico la respuesta es
porque resulta que la geometría elíptica
también llamada esférica es justamente
la geometría que rige nuestro mundo
porque a pesar de lo que quieran creer
la tierra es redonda y esta geometría es
la que se ocupa para calcular las
trayectorias de los barcos las tractores
marítimas o la de los aviones como la
que el matemático en el aeropuerto y la
geometría hiperbólica es nada más y nada
menos que la geometría que ocupó un tal
albert einstein para describir el
espacio-tiempo es decir la geometría que
cumple nuestro universo
dos teorías distintas menos tres teorías
distintas tres axiomas distintas
y las tres teorías son perfectamente
válidas como pueden ver los axiomas ya
no están condenados a hacer estas
verdades absolutas sino unas verdades
flexibles que nos permiten construir
toda clase de realidades a partir de
toda clase de verdades distintas y todas
perfectamente congruentes y válidas
entonces
el segundo pilar de las matemáticas es
la creatividad porque porque ahora los
matemáticos hacemos verdades gracias a
nuestra creatividad pero sin perderle la
rigurosidad que nos permite llegar a
esas nuevas verdades
esto es las geometrías nutri dianas son
solo ejemplo que grandes matemáticos nos
dejaron por allá del año 1700
del año 1700 y cuál bola de nieve la
cantidad de matemáticas que se han hecho
desde ese entonces ha sido
inconmensurable mente mayor que los
milenios posteriores anteriores perdón
tan solo para poner números en los
últimos tres años tres años nada más se
han hecho más de 670.000 trabajos acerca
de nuevas matemáticas y cada año va en
aumento con teorías de fronteras como la
teoría de nudos que sirve para estudiar
el adn la inteligencia artificial de la
que todo mundo ya está hablando o
teorías con nombres terroríficos como el
álgebra homo lógica que hay gente
ocupando la para estudiar cosas tan
abstractas como la música
pero más allá de sus aplicaciones hacer
matemáticas es hacer volar la
imaginación con todo lo que podemos
crear pero al mismo tiempo con los pies
bien planteados sobre la tierra gracias
a la rigurosidad y así como los
astrónomos exploran los confines del
universo a través de sus telescopios
nosotros exploramos los confines de la
matemática a través de nuestras ideas y
si alguna de las dos no tiene límite
pues estoy seguro que las matemáticas no
lo tienen damas y caballeros las
matemáticas no están hechas apenas están
comenzando muchas gracias
[Aplausos]